[Music]  while his Dancing with the Stars  co-stars are off on the show's summer  tour Pro Val Chmerkovskiy is taking in a  European tour and with a special lady by  his side let her take the the challenge  for several days Val and fellow dancer  Jenna Johnson posted pics from the same  exotic European location but they did  not include each other in those photos  until this Val putting a photo of Jenna  in his Instagram story and captioning it  quote I got the best view and Jenna  posted a photo of her snazzle e clad boy  of summer writing views you date anyway  now figuring it up the two have been a  rumored couple on and off since early  2016 and now from the Amalfi Coast to  the island of Sardinia and romantic Rome  seems like a recipe for summer lovin to  us  [Music]  you